each year at commencement
our university recognizes an exceptional
group of individuals
with honorary degrees these degrees are
the most significant distinction
conferred by the yale corporation the
university's board of trustees to signal
pioneering achievement in a field
or conspicuous and exemplary
contribution to the common good
though we cannot adorn this year's
honorary degree recipients in their
academic hoods
or applaud their accomplishments as they
stand on the commencement stage
we gather virtually to recognize their
achievements
and we express our gratitude for the
ways they have expanded
the frontiers of knowledge and enriched
our world
through science art
innovation and service
today we honor nine individuals who
serve as examples to our graduates
and members of the yale community they
encourage us to
aspire to excellence and to value those
elements
of human character that they embody
creativity curiosity discipline
integrity and a passion for public
service
collectively they represent yale's
highest aspirations as a university
dedicated
to light and truth
and their association with the class of
2021 honors the students who
graduate today
now it is my distinct pleasure to
announce
the 2021 honorary degree recipients
and to confer their degrees
for the degree of doctor of fine arts
eva duvernay filmmaker
creator and critic you portray the
richness and variety of human experience
from all
angles by elevating others you bring new
stories into focus and amplify voices we
need to hear
hollywood maverick for challenging us to
reckon with our past and our present and
for working to change both an
industry and society yale is
pleased to confer on you this doctor of
fine arts degree
for the degree of doctor of social
science daniel todd gilbert
social psychologist fearless
investigator
generous teacher you connect the
laboratory to our lives
applying the fruits of research to our
search
for happiness with humor and
understanding
you explore memory imagination and
emotion helping us look
more clearly to the future for stumbling
on answers to life's great questions
and sharing them widely yael is happy to
award you
the degree of doctor of social science
for the degree of doctor of laws dolores
c huerta community organizer
from the fields to the state house you
have united
people in pursuit of justice your skills
as an organizer are matched by the
strength of your convictions
that there is dignity and labor that
rights are worth fighting for
and that people power is the strongest
force on earth
courageous advocate for showing us that
yes we can change the world we are
honored to present you
with this doctor of law's degree
for the degree of doctor of humanities
robert ferris thompson
art historian scholar of improvisation
connoisseur of cool your work celebrates
the sights sounds and towering
achievements of the black atlantic
with joyful curiosity you explore the
flash of the spirit
while mentoring generations of students
professor of mambo beloved t
for contributing so much to the rhythm
of our lives
yale is privileged to present you one of
our own
with your fourth yell degree doctor
of humanities for the degree of doctor
of medical sciences
donald r hopkins physician and
epidemiologist
courageous and brilliant warrior against
disease
you have slain the fiery serpent and
subdued the greatest killer
from atlanta to sierra leone and
bedsides around the globe
you purged ancient plagues and delivered
healing to millions
an appreciation of your dogged
determination and life-saving compassion
we humbly bestow on you the degree
of doctor of medical sciences
for the degree of doctor of humane
letters stephen colbert
writer and comedian modern day jester
your satires and setups have shaped our
culture
and our politics whether playing a
character
playing it straight or having it both
ways
you take us beyond truthiness and turn
our attention to urgent issues
award-winning wit for using your
creativity
talent and craft to engage us in the
work of democracy
we are delighted to confer on you this
doctor of humane letters degree
for the degree of doctor of letters judy
bloom
author gifted storyteller
nothing is off limits and no taboo is
too great for your
uncensored and honest voice treasured by
readers young and old you pushed past
shame and convention to help us
understand the world
and our place in it for championing the
freedom to imagine
while encouraging us to love ourselves
yell is forever proud to award you
this doctor of letters degree
for the degree of doctor of science
nergis malvavala
astrophysicist
intrepid explorer inspiring role model
your work shifts paradigms and opens new
windows onto the universe
with precision and originality you have
devised instruments that will detect
ripples in the vast expanse of space and
time
raising ever larger questions about the
enigmas of the cosmos
in recognition of your stellar
discoveries we
gratefully present you with the degree
of doctor of science
for the degree of doctor of divinity
rabbi lord jonathan
sachs religious leader championing
dialogue over division rabbi lord
jonathan sachs
called us to work together to fulfill
our responsibilities
and heal the world a respected scholar
esteemed teacher of torah and light unto
the nations
he dedicated his life to serving others
showing us what it means to put we
before i in recognition
of his wise and steadfast moral
leadership yale is honored to confer
this doctor of divinity degree
posthumously
on rabbi lord jonathan sachs
zachar tadik levraka
on behalf of the yale community i send
my most heartfelt congratulations to
all of you the entire university joins
me in applauding your accomplishments
and welcome to the class of 2021
you